who would have thought that water in a
can would become the second best-selling
drink on Amazon and not only there
liquid death is believed to be the
fastest growing non-alcoholic beverage
of all time it sold its first can in
2019 and raked in 3 million in Revenue
that year in 2022 the company's Revenue
soared to 130 million and is currently
valued at 700 million
CEO Mike Cesario recognized that many
people were looking for a more
environmentally friendly alternative to
plastic water bottles what is liquid
depth are these kids drinking by
packaging water in a can of what looks
like craft beer liquid death created a
unique identity but it wasn't just the
packaging that made liquid death cool
it's the wicked marketing
for years a bunch of Market boys have
tricked you into thinking that water is
just some girly drink for yoga moms just
look at all the cute brand names and
dainty little bottles well hold on to
your hot dogs
because I got news water isn't cute
water is deadly their ads are funny and
satirical drawing people to the Brand's
edginess yeah Mountain Water made from
the deadliest stuff on Earth
one of the top comments on this video is
I don't mind commercials when they are
as entertaining as this Mike told the
non-profit news organization Marketplace
if you can make people laugh they will
have a deeper connection with your brand
regardless of the functional differences
of your liquid big companies think they
set themselves apart because of unique
ingredients but those can be replicated
easily strong Brands mean more to people
than the product itself so the CEO of
liquid death is admitting it's not even
about the taste of the drink not the
worst water I've ever tasted
Mike thinks of his beverage startup as
being like Saturday Night Live with
comedians writing the skits for years he
worked on marketing campaigns including
for the dairy brand organic valley which
produced this hilarious commercial about
their protein shake just tell a bro it
has a ton of protein and he'll pound the
out of it
that sense of humor is written all over
the cans the blurb on the side reads
when a group of teenagers set off into
the mountains for a weekend of drinking
regular water in plastic bottles they
became hunted by an aluminum can of
Mountain Water that was dead set on
murdering their thirst and recycling
their souls the can draws inspiration
from the kind of artwork on popular
energy drinks
Mike actually got the idea for liquid
death while attending the van's Warp
Tour which was sponsored by the energy
drink Monster
he noticed that band members didn't want
to consume energy drinks for health
reasons so monster gave them cans filled
with water so they could still promote
the brand these cans of Monster Tour
water were not for sale to the public
Mike thought to himself why not sell
water in a can and Market it in the same
fun and rebellious way as energy drinks
or beer and it just so happens that
alcohol consumption appears to be on the
decline for young people among American
adults Gallup showed that those aged 18
to 34 are less likely to drink alcohol
than those aged 35 to 54. a large UK
study in 2019 showed 26 percent of young
people in England are not drinking at
all
[Music]
liquid death says a quarter of its
consumers are Jen's ears between 18 to
25 years old its Tick Tock account is
the second most followed of any beverage
brand that I could find after Red Bull
even though some investors thought it
was a dumb idea Mike knew he was onto
something the company created buzz on
social media even before launching the
product to see if it had potential
without even having a real product in
four months we have more social
followers than Aquafina look how many
people are messaging us asking where
they can get this look how many people
are sharing images of a beverage product
like who shares an image of a beverage
and how often on social media not too
often your fans are so loyal that
they're getting the brand permanently
etched on their skin the company says
they know of at least 300 people with
liquid death tattoos liquid death has
also built brand loyalty through unusual
celebrity endorsements like releasing a
limited edition line of Tony Hawk
skateboards infused with his blood and
we're going to use it for skateboard
Graphics the idea was so provocative
that several news outlets covered it
resulting in free publicity liquid death
has expanded its lineup from selling
Mountain Water and sparkling to include
flavored water and Iced Teas with witty
names that are play on phrases convicted
melon convicted felon Grim leafer Grim
Reaper rest in Peach rest in peace
liquid death is a master class in the
art of marketing it has struck the right
balance by being provocative enough to
stand out while not crossing the line
into offensiveness liquid death's goal
is to become a multi-billion dollar
Beverage Company like Red Bull I
recently used the blinkist app to absorb
the key Concepts on how to build a great
company from the best-selling book good
to gray it took only 17 minutes to soak
up all the lessons flinkist taught me
that great companies are focused on what
they're uniquely good at the Hedgehog
concept is based on the idea that
hedgehogs do one thing really well curl
up into a protective ball blinkist
allows you to understand the key ideas
and Concepts from 5500 non-fiction books
in text in audio 4. blinkist has a new
feature blinkist connect which lets you
share your Premium plan for free with
someone else even though it's shared
both accounts are separate you can get
25 off blinkist premium and enjoy two
memberships for the price of one to try
out blinkist for free for seven days you
can head to the custom link in my
description blinkist.com newsthink